[Music]
we are currently on a pace to finish by
august the 31st
the sooner we can finish the better but
the completion by august 31st depends
upon the taliban continuing to cooperate
and allow access to the airport for
those who were trans were transporting
out and no disruptions to our operations
when joe biden spoke he was really
sending a message to the taliban as well
as to the american people to the
american people we've got this we can
get this done by august 31st to the
taliban we've got this we can get this
done by august the 31st as long as you
don't get in the way there was a
security briefing on capitol hill in the
last few hours it was confidential but
many of the people who were in that
meeting walked out saying they don't
think that the biden administration is
going to hit this deadline
we will not allow an extension beyond
august 31st so the u.s should remove and
evacuate all personnel by the set
deadline all their contractors must
leave we are not happy to extend the
deadline and after that we will have a
separate stance and position following
the deadline
[Music]
with no extension of the august 31st
deadline there are mounting concerns for
tens of thousands of afghans that want
to leave this country
the taliban says they have nothing to
fear and that there will be no reprisals
against people who have worked with nato
foreign organizations or the media in
the past
but trusting the taliban on the basis of
their words alone is something that many
afghans and the international community
find it very difficult to do
we need to have a procedure and a plan
in place security force is not
operational they are not trained to deal
with women that's why we're stopping
women from going to work we ask women to
stay home and their salaries will be
resuming
come back to work when we have a system
in place
[Music]
you